I think I have,
if I want to,
I like to say three hours a day,
but that's,
you know,
probably in a day when I'm on my desk
and not a,
you know,
in New York City or something,
but I think I read more than most people
in those younger than me who are so busy
doing things.
So,
uh,
I have the leisure time actually to,
to read and I think that's what we've
lost now in sort of science today is
leisure a quick.
And I had plenty of leisure because
nothing was happening.
We were trying to find the DNA
structure,
one hundreds of new facts,
you know,
almost every week that we might learn
about.
And uh,
so now people really defensively wanted
to be sure that they're,
uh,
you know,
people will think they're experts.
So they become more and more narrow
experts and not very broad.
And I still can't get over when I was at
a large pharmaceutical company.
They half jokingly,
but I'm sure the reality was true.
He had a thousand PHD technicians.
As you got your phd,
you were just a technician.
No one was hiring into a very narrow
thing,
not show any,
you know,
big thoughts at all.
So,
uh,
with so many facts,
but I missed our thinkers,
uh,
the uh,
or smart now,
don't even when I was boy,
smart people respect it.
Now it's,
you know,
people will do things who doors.
And uh,
also you find that,
you know,
there hadn't been one person doing it.
There are 15 names on the paper.
And,
uh,
our famous paper for instance,
could have included Maurice Wilkins name
out because he was really part of a,
you didn't make the final discovery,
but he was,
you know,
part of this stuff just for Ford.
So we asked him to put his name on the
paper and I said,
no,
a three person pepper.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the,
I'm worried about people really
thinking
big.
I don't find many people who do.
So now,
uh,
the,
when I was a student at University of
Chicago,
Robert Hutchinson is free shed.
The function of the College of the
University of Chicago is to prepare you
for greatness.
He used those words because,
uh,
our educational is largely reading the
great books and you were reading the
great books,
not to,
uh,
be a teacher,
but to let you go beyond the great books
on producing another great book.
So that was how he saw it.
Of course,
he would know that,
that wouldn't happen very often,
but it was still there that,
uh,
and it certainly in dreams of people,
you know,
that they do something big was the time
they keep it secret because,
you know,
it's so unrealistic and often then you
get braggers who tell you you're doing
something great and,
uh,
don't believe them.
But nonetheless,
you know,
and some sort of quiet way you should,
uh,
have big dreams.
Stop having 15 names on a paper.
So,
you know,
I accept the fact the rest really didn't
think at all about this and you should
really,
you know,
were just technicians in,
in,
you know,
in a real sense.
And uh,
uh,
reserve authors share for people who put
together sentences.
I mean,
you know,
the,
uh,
the answer,
whereas a very outset,
factories with the mother of a scientist
now have their second secondhand over
paper where there are 20 other people on
the paper and she'd wonder,
is he going anywhere?
So,
uh,
and uh,
and another problem may be though it was
against everything we now say we may be
trained to,
when they scientists,
that's his.
We're training people who really don't
want to think.
They just want to have jobs and uh,
they consume money and uh,
so you'd lose some,
you know,
if you cut off,
people didn't have real dream.
But,
uh,
if you going into science,
I think,
you know,
better go in with the dream,
then maybe you two would get a Nobel
prize.
It's not that,
you know,
I went in,
I thought I was very bright and I was
going to get one,
but I'll confessional,
uh,
you know,
I knew what it was and quick games he
was otherwise because I saw that
structure,
I thought we're going to get a Nobel
prize.
You know,
that was within five minutes.
It was so obvious.